un silence qui en dit long pour exprimer
la colère pour réclamer plus d'actions
comme des hausses de salaire contre
l'inflation galopante
les grèves de divers corps de métiers se
multiplient au Royaume-Uni dans un bras
de fer entre des syndicats et le
gouvernement conservateurs
d'ennemis de la libre entreprise durant
son discours de clôture du concret
conservateur
un congrès mouvementé marqué par une
fronde au sein de son parti partager sur
sa vision socio-économique les Strauss a
dû faire volte-face en s'excusant au
sujet de la baisse des pots pour les
plus riches
la mesure la plus controversée d'un mini
budget largement financé par la dette et
qui affolé les marchés fait plonger les
conservateurs dans les sondages indignez
une bonne partie des Britanniques
se déléguer reconnaît qu'il faisait
partie de la minorité en faveur de cette
baisse
parce que dit-il la fiscalité est la
seule façon de stimuler l'économie
strass jurent qu'elle va garder le cap
16 et c'est voulu à la fois combative et
optimiste pour allier ses troupes
en assurant comprendre la résistance au
changement aux perturbations
tout le monde profitera du résultat la
croissance sa priorité économique
[Applaudissements]
mais ces critiques trouvent que n'en
fait pas assez pour des millions de
Britanniques qui n'y arrivent plus
abirmingham deuxième ville du pays le
quart de la population vit dans la
pauvreté selon les autorités locales
ce responsable du programme
d'alimentation soutient que les réserves
ont fondu en deux semaines
il explique que le gel des factures
d'électricité et de gaz par le
gouvernement ne suffira pas pour bien
des gens
réunis dans un congrès coûteux tout prêt
ça vraiment ce que c'est de vivre ici
n'a pas la compétence l'intégrité et
l'empathie nécessaire pour être en phase
avec l'électorat et l'opposition et pour
montrer que le Royaume-Uni est entre
bonne main
elle ajoute que la leader conservatrice
n'a pas vraiment eu de lune de miel
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir remove que
le parti espérait que ça irait mieux
après avoir montré la porte à boys
Johnson personne n'avait imaginé une
telle dégringolade
que si une élection avait lieu
aujourd'hui l'opposition travailler
c'est l'emporterait haut la main selon
les récents sondages et cherche à
affirmer son autorité au sein de son
parti elle pourrait avoir de la
difficulté à rester jusqu'au prochaines
élections générales prévues dans deux
ans surtout si les conservateurs malgré
leur unité affichée en fin de congrès
finissent par trouver qu'elle pourrait
miner leur chance de réélection ici
Yannick Béraud Radio-Canada Birmingham